hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
as I test the new HTC One m8 a bit more
to give you guys my full review I've
been messing around with these first
party accessories and I just can't help
but talk about this dot view case and
heck it's been a while since I did an
accessory review so thumbs up for that
so the m8 is probably one of the best
build phones out there and I really
wouldn't even suggest putting a case on
it because it's built so well and it'll
do just fine naked but if you are going
to put a case on your m8 it should
definitely be this one so first party
cases from the manufacturer have the
opportunity to be specifically designed
for the device and they usually have
some pretty great integration and
sometimes they have a trick or two up
their sleeve a great example would be
the smart cover for the iPad most people
are familiar with that but not every
first party case is designed well but
for 50 bucks here which is pretty steep
for a case you get some pretty boss
functionality added to the phone that
just flat-out looks really cool so first
of all when the case is closed and you
open it I guess there's a magnet or
sensor in there that automatically turns
on the display so that's nice you can
also double tap the case to wake it to
give you a standard glance at the time
and the weather so the time up top and
the weather and temperature flash along
the bottom for a few seconds you can
also double tap to turn them back off
but what's even cooler here is you can
swipe down on the case and it opens up
voice commands that you can tell it to
text someone or call someone and it'll
do it without you ever having to open up
the case now this is HTC use voice
commands not Google now or anything so
you won't have the same functionality as
saying okay Google on a moto X or
something but it's definitely still a
nice touch and it's quick easy access
and on top of all of that this case also
shows you your most recent notification
for stuff like calendar events messages
missed calls and even live for incoming
calls so you have the case closed you
get a call you can swipe on the case to
answer the call and then talk without
even removing it kind of like samsung's
SVU case and then when you're done
talking you can also end the call with
another swipe on the case and ever even
open the cover to begin with
now just so we're clear there's no
display built into the case there's just
a ton of translucent dots that let you
view into a very special mode that's
activated when this case is on your
phone so I guess that's explained by the
name dot view case and as long as you're
not activating it ridiculously often it
shouldn't have too much of an effect on
your battery life since you're waking
your phone the same amount of times just
get a slightly better looking
information summary so I think it's
awesome definitely a really unique
concept that legit adds value instead of
just being a silly gimmick or just
selling a case for the sake of being a
case and it's supposed to be available
soon in red blue orange black green and
this gray that I have here and I dig it
I normally don't do case reviews
obviously but imagine first-party cases
is this nice from more manufacturers
that'd be awesome
pretty much everyone I've shown this to
thinks it's basically the coolest case
ever and I'm gonna have to agree on that
one here so there you go just a quick
look at one of the first party
accessories for the HTC One m8 if you
haven't already seen my video going over
my first impressions of the new phone
itself that will be the first link below
that like button for you to check out it
was uploaded yesterday and I'm diggin it
so far so I'm gonna go again and get
back to testing the phone and the
subtour project edit and all the rest of
the stuff I have to do so thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one peace